- We're back for part two of
our Worth It Taiwan series.
Today, we're doing soup.
- Taiwan style.
It's amazing 'cause it's so hot in Taiwan,
and yet, they love their soup here.
- It's eaten for breakfast,
lunch and dinner,
so many great dishes to try.
But before we get there,
Steven where are we?
- We are here at the Jingzaijiao
Tile-paved Salt Fields.
Is that right Inga?
- Jingzaijiao.
- Historically one of the earliest
salt-producing areas of Taiwan.
Ocean water comes in,
the sun evaporates it,
and you're left with salt.
Speaking of salty liquids.
- Sweat?
- No.
- Oh.
- We're doing soup.
- Today on Worth It,
we're going to be trying
three Taiwanese soups
at three drastically
different price points
to find out which one is the
most worth it at its price.
- It's so windy.
- The typhoon just passed.
- We're heading a little bit
north of the city of Tainan
to where, Inga?
- We're going to Chiayi
to have some fish soup
at Lin Cong Ming Yu Tang.
- Lin is my last name,
and cong ming is smart,
so we're just going to,
like, the smart version of me
fish place.
- Oh wow.
That'll be a extra special treat.
(jazzy music)
- Taiwan is very hot.
- Yes.
- [Steven] Soup is a very hot food.
Why do Taiwanese people love soup so much?
Taiwan was a poor place.
It's easier to feel full
adding soup to the meal.
We've been serving this soup for the past
60 years, since my grandfather's time.
What's special about this is we
cook 100 servings in one go.
The taste can only be acquired by using
such big amounts of ingredients.
The essence of the abundant ingredients is
condensed in one bowl of soup.
- What kind of fish is in the soup?
We mainly use silver carp
and salmon in our soup.
Silver carp is a native Taiwanese river fish.
Our salmon is imported and it's quite
popular among gourmets.
Our broth base is made with pork bone and
water, cooking from 8 a.m. until 9 p.m.
Meanwhile, preparing the rest of the ingredients.
Napa cabbage
Garlic
Onion
Scallion
Non-GMO tofu
Next step is chopping up the
fish and deep-frying them.
Why is the fish fried and
then added afterwards?
There was no refrigerating to preserve
the fish back then in Taiwan.
My grandpa opted for deep-
frying to dehydrate the fish.
It also helps to absorb the broth
when submerged in the soup.
I noticed that customers can
come back with their bowls
and get more broth.
It's a tradition of the restaurant.
We strive to treat our customers like family.
You should eat to your heart's content at home.
It's also thanks to the continuous support of our customers
that we can cook in such great quantity.
That allows a continuous flow
of soup for everyone to share.
(cash register dings)
- Ooh!
- Oh...
Yay...
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
- What's the plate for?
- For the fish bone.
- Oh, fish bones.
- Oh...
- Is this your beer?
- Yes, it's my fish beer.
- Cheers, Steven.
(bottles clink)
(trumpet music)
Look at that logo.
Fish soup beer, I am blown away.
- Cheers in Mandarin is...
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
Is that right?
(Andrew speaks in foreign language)
- Okay, that was very unexpected.
Wow, again.
- Wow, a thousand times.
- This is very refreshing.
- It is.
- Give me one word.
- Wow.
- [Steven] So this is the
marquis piece right here.
I'm just gonna bite into this.
(Andrew groans in satisfaction)
- This is like a dish that dares you
to want something else.
You want vegetables?
Boom, we got it.
You want tofu?
Forget about it.
You want pork?
We got it right here.
You want fish? Boom.
Fry it? We can do it.
- Yeah, when she was
listing the ingredients,
it was just like the NBA All-Star Game.
And here we have the tofu!
Next up, cabbage!
- Y'all ready for this?
(Steven laughs)
Chiayi is also very famous for
turkey meat sauce over rice.
Customers always get the combo of
turkey rice and fish head soup in here.
Turkey rice.
I love how this soup,
with all of this stuff,
they were like,
"Nah, you still need some turkey rice."
- That's right.
If there's one thing we
learned here in Taiwan,
you cannot leave a restaurant hungry.
They will assault you with food.
In the most lovingly way possible.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
Mm, it's just turkey meat
and fat on a bowl of rice.
It's great.
If you weren't an adventurous eater,
this would seem like a scary bowl of food,
but it all just kind of
blends into this big soft hug.
I don't know.
It tastes nice.
It's a kind taste.
- That's exactly how you
say it in Mandarin though.
- Really?
- Good eat, right?
Good taste.
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
- Means good eat, good taste, yeah.
- Let's spread the kindness.
(Andrew slaps hand on table)
- Once I finish this meal,
it will be so long until
I get to eat this again.
And that makes me sad.
- I know, this whole
trip is actually just--
- It's sad.
- The worst.
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
- That soup was incredible.
In the rainbow of soup to stew,
this was somewhere in
the middle in like the--
- Stoup?
- Stoup
section, yeah.
- There it is!
- So before we get to our next soup,
we decided to get some treats
at the Garden Night Market in Tainan.
- [Steven] This is my favorite
treat at Night Market.
It is a peanut roll with
ice cream and cilantro.
- [Andrew] What?
Cilantro in a dessert?
I guess it makes sense,
we put mint in desserts,
and that's just
another green leaf.
- Oh, I didn't even
think of that.
Cheers?
- Cheers.
- [Steven] Huh?
Huh?
- Oh.
I like dessert cilantro.
So our next soup is actually
going to be hot pot.
- Hot pot fact!
- Archeologists have found pots
from two thousand years ago
that may have been used
to make an early iteration
of hot pot.
These were found in the
Anhui province of China.
- Wow, old hot pot.
Dude, hot pot for me,
every Thanksgiving in the Lin family,
we always, always, always eat hot pot.
- It would make sense that soup was one
of the oldest things humans ate.
- Yeah just water, throw some
stuff in there and eat it.
- Tomorrow, hot pot.
Inga where are we going?
- We are going to A Yu Niu Rou Sha Sha Guo
to eat some beef soup.
- That's what I'm talking about.
Beef soup.
Get that hot pot, throw
some beef in there,
throw some soup in there,
throw some veggies in there.
Whatever you want, we're gonna eat it.
(Steven coughs)
Excuse me.
I choked on a peanut.
Why do you love hot pot so much?
Life is perfect while you enjoy this
pot of delicious broth and beef.
Room temperature beef shabu-shabu
is known for its freshness.
The cattle are raised in the
mountains all over Taiwan.
Then butchered in the government-run
slaughterhouse in the Shanhua District of Tainan.
The beef comes straight from there
after being butchered and inspected.
- How often do you get the deliveries?
Every meal.
Every meal?
For example, the beef served now during
lunch was butchered this morning.
Therefore the beef has this natural
sweetness and QQ (chewy) texture.
We saw that it arrived by taxi.
Is it always come by taxi?
We paid the cab to pick it up because
we're too busy in the store.
That's so cool, the meat
takes a cab to every meal.
(everybody laughing)
It takes about 6-8 hours to make the broth.
The first layer of ingredients is beef bones.
Second layer is stacks of beef brisket.
We use about 264 pounds of brisket for the broth.
Topping the pot with one bag of
vegetables and fruits each.
There's also vegetables
in the dish already?
The vegetables in the small pot is to
bring out the taste of the broth.
Cabbage is the star of the pot.
The vegetables really complement the
broth and make the hot pot perfect.
For someone who's never
had hot pot before,
how do you eat it?
Dip the beef in the boiling soup around
3 times/5 seconds and it's ready to eat.
I always recommend eating without condiments first.
For the second bite, try the beef with
a bit of our special sauce.
My husband is in charge of extracting
the prime cut out of the beef.
The freshly butchered beef is quite soft and
requires great skills with the knife.
He is so good with the knife! Every piece
comes out with the same thickness!
You also have this pork rice.
It's free for all the customers?
My husband is a generous guy.
He wants the customers to have the rice to
go with the delicious beef shabu-shabu.
Perfect combination!
(everybody laughing)
(cash register dings)
(jazzy music)
(Andrew and Steven speak
in foreign language)
We've eaten a lot of beef on this show,
but this is some of the
prettiest beef I've ever seen.
The color is ridiculous.
Cold-brewed oolong.
This is one of the coolest things.
It's like, tea snow globe.
And it's got the net in the--
- [Steven] No way!
- [Andrew and Steven] Cheers.
- Mm.
- [Andrew] You wanna start with this one?
- [Steven] Let's do it, the shoulder cap.
- Cheers, Steven.
- Whoa.
- [Andrew] One, two,
three.
- Wow.
Going in.
One.
Two, oh no!
(Andrew laughs)
- This smells incredible.
- Cheers.
- Oh, that's nice beef.
- We're just getting to
eat really nice steak.
- Yeah.
- With soup.
- And you get to eat it the
second it's done cooking.
- Mm!
- I'm gonna try the same
piece of meat this time,
but now dip it.
Shabu, shabu.
Ooh.
- Shabu.
- That rocks.
- Can I get in there?
- Yeah.
You should absolutely.
- All right.
One.
Two.
- Whoa.
- Three.
- Like you're baptizing the meat.
(Steven cheers)
- [Andrew] The dip is awesome.
- Okay.
That's doing it right.
- There's two great ways to enjoy beef.
You either cook it very briefly
or you cook it a really long time.
This is the best of both worlds.
The quick cook beef and also
the super long cook beef.
- 'Cause the soup is a 10 to 12 hour,
steeped in beef bone soup.
- But enough about beef.
Pork break.
- Pork break.
(Andrew and Steven groan in satisfaction)
- At first this did not make sense to me.
But it's because the beef is so precious,
it breaks up the flow,
so I don't just crush my
plate of beef all in one bite,
like I want to.
- Well, and also, this
bowl of rice is bringing me
more comfort than my body pillow.
- What?
- I've had the same one for over 10 years.
It's hard to sleep without it.
- [Adam] Change pillows
more frequently.
- Wow.
- No, I wash it.
- That explains a lot about you.
- It's like a teddy bear.
We all have that, like, item.
- Yeah but now mine is
in my parents' attic,
because I stopped sleeping
with it after the age of eight.
- Why would you give up
something that's so comfortable?
- All right, we're gonna
have the broth now.
We've finally reached the
soup part of the meal.
Ooh, the smell though.
- Cheers.
- Ooh, that is nice.
It's not so beefy, actually.
It's got like--
- Fruity flavor.
- Yeah.
- Like, apples or something.
This is the best way
to close out this meal.
- Yeah, this nice gentle landing.
It's like when you have a delicious sauce
and you want a piece of bread to mop it up
to get all of the sauce.
Here, you just drink the sauce.
(patrons talking in background)
- Hot pot.
- That hot pot was so good.
Okay, so we've come to
Taichung for our final soup.
But before we have that, we're
gonna have some cold drinks.
- That's right.
We're going to Ten Ren,
one of my favorite
places in the States, so.
About to be having it here in Taiwan,
where it's actually from.
- So we've got oolong
tea, and a black tea boba.
Confession time.
I'm not the biggest fan of boba.
- That's fine.
- I just, eating while drinking, I don't--
- Isn't that what soup is?
- Soup is drinking while eating.
It's completely different,
don't get it twisted.
- Cheers.
(glasses clink)
Mm.
- That's what I like.
Unsweetened, nice ice tea.
That's all I want.
Instead of another soup fact,
we're actually gonna have a boba fact.
- [Steven] Boba fact.
- Boba tea was invented
in the 1980s in Taichung.
- Oh, some genius out here put
boba and milk tea together.
There're controversies around
who actually invented boba milk tea.
There's multiple reports
of different people, so.
- Interesting.
We're now on our way to Gubami,
where we're going to see Chef Chen
to try her beef noodle soup.
- [Steven] The iconic dish of Taiwan.
- We've had it a few
times off-camera so far,
just for our crew meals and such,
and it's usually a very inexpensive dish.
Five or six US dollars equivalent.
But today's is going to
be a little more deluxe.
- It's gonna cost around 30 US dollars,
which is a lot for beef noodle soup.
But it's gonna be really good.
- Gubami is beef noodles
in Taiwanese dialect.
- Why do you think Taiwan loves
their beef noodle soup so much?
- It's fast, and also it's luxury.
You have a big bowl of
noodle soup and meat.
I never really see restaurants
can do all three good.
I wanna do things the best,
so when I do noodles, I want
to find out the best formula.
We test with different flours
for almost, six months I would say.
We want the noodles to be
al dente in the middle,
but also the outside can
absorb a little bit the soup.
We use the Japanese wagyu beef shank
and also we have a condiment
of smoked bone marrow
and on top of it, we have some
shabu shabu of the beef shank
to give two different
textures of the meat.
- What is your background in cooking?
Like, where did you come from?
- I learned in Paris and I
traveled to States a little bit,
and then I come back.
I started my French
restaurant 10 years ago.
Very fine dining, it
was my dream restaurant.
But it's in Taichung, it's very weird.
I think Taiwan people,
they like something casual.
I want to do something smaller
and now I have the bar,
I have noodle shop.
I always just trying
to do something I like.
(Chef Chen laughs)
It looks like very refined,
but I didn't do it on purpose.
I just trying to make it good,
and then it becomes this way.
- [Steven] Mm.
(cash register dings)
- Look at this.
That's not soup.
We have tofu skin, cooked
in some of the beef stock.
This is the radish with
lemon and olive oil.
Zucchini, confit in goose fat.
Some kind of green bean and
beef mushroom deliciousness.
- I know there's a lot of
delicious stuff in front of us,
I cannot wait for the soup right now,
but I will be patient.
(jazzy music)
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on the soup.
(Andrew laughs)
That is damn good.
- [Andrew And Steven] Green bean.
(jazzy music)
- Oh, I did not think that
was gonna taste like that.
- What?
(Andrew laughs)
- It's a smoky, porky, green bean.
Tofu skin.
- That looks super juicy.
And meaty.
Cheers.
- That's the best one.
- No, this is the best one.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
- [Steven] Zucchini.
- Confit in goose fat.
(jazzy music)
Every time I eat something green,
I expect it to taste
like a crisp vegetable.
Instead it tastes like a fatty animal.
This is awesome.
- Wow, finally the beef.
(jazzy music)
- Oh!
- I'm ready to eat some
beef noodle soup right now.
- Ooh, thank you.
All right.
- Smell this thing!
- Oh...
- I can't believe this.
I can't believe this.
- Yeah.
- I can't believe this.
- [Andrew] This is a $30 bowl of soup.
- Broth cheers.
(jazzy music)
(Andrew exhales)
- Okay.
- I didn't think a beef
taste could be refreshing.
- Yeah, shabu shabu?
- Yeah, let's do the
choice cut meat on top.
(jazzy music)
- Wow.
- Very flavorful beef, okay.
- Jeez!
That is good.
I literally just ate a
pastrami sandwich in one bite.
- Yeah.
- And the juices of the
soup just bursting out.
Inga have some.
Come, come, come.
- This is so good.
(slurping sounds)
- Those are great noodles!
Springy, chewy.
Look at that beef.
Wow.
Holy crap, I didn't think it
was going to be that soft.
What?
- Yeah.
(crew laughing in the background)
- It's like softer than taffy.
Softer than, it's somewhere...
- You gotta be kidding me!
- Okay, let's add the bone marrow.
This is like buttering
already buttered bread.
(slurping sounds)
(Steven exhales)
- Gah, whoa.
Including all the steaks we've eaten,
this beef, best beef
taste I've ever tasted.
And the best part?
You get to eat noodles the whole time.
It's like usually a steak,
you're just eating steak.
Pretty fun, but okay.
Noodles the whole time?
(both laugh)
- Yeah, I've had a lot of
beef noodle soup before,
and it's never bad, it's always
satisfying and comforting.
But this one is like,
a boy was born in Akron, Ohio,
awarded him the chosen
one in an ESPN magazine
when he was 14,
turned out to be a
great basketball player.
- Who is this?
- LeBron James.
- Oh, goddammit.
Every time.
- Gubami.
- One of the best soup
dishes I've ever had,
one of the best noodle
one of the best beef dishes I've ever had.
- I like what you did there.
- Before we get to our Worth It winners,
Andrew, what was your favorite
thing that was not a soup
in this episode?
- The craft beer at Smart Fish.
- [Steven] Oh.
- I never thought I'd see a
beer with a fish soup logo.
What was your favorite non-soup thing?
- Beef taxi.
There's not even a escort.
Just beef in the taxi, beef out the taxi.
- Okay Steven, which soup
was most worth it to you?
- I thought Smart Fish
soup was gonna be my winner
when we ate there,
I thought the beef hot
pot was gonna be my winner
when we ate there,
but Gubami is my Worth It winner today.
So beefy, just so much
thought put into it.
- My Worth It winner goes to Smart Fish.
- Oh.
- Fish soup was crazy.
Truly one of the most unique
dishes I've ever eaten.
- Inga and Annie?
- Gubami.
- What?
Adam, who's your Worth It winner?
- [Adam] Gubami.
(Andrew sputters)
(Inga laughs)
- I've never been so,
this is a Worth It first.
- I win today!
- That's it for Worth It Taiwan soup.
We have one more episode in
this miniseries coming up next.
Steven, what is it?
- Chicken!
(upbeat music)
We're in Taiwan!
We're back with a three-part mini-series.
Joining us on all of our episodes,
our friend, translator,
- [Andrew] Fellow Buzzfeed producer,
- Inga Lam!
- Taipei! (laughing)
- We're gonna be seeing some
great modes of transportation,
some fun games, some tricks, some treats,
and some delights.
You know how you know we're in Taiwan?
The beautiful 101 Tower.
And because it's steamy,
which is perfect for the first food
that we're doing in our trip: dumplings,
a food that's often cooked with steam.
- Great transition.
Today on Worth It, we're gonna
be trying three dumplings
at three drastically different
price points to find out
which one is the most
worth it at its price.
- I am so excited to do dumplings.
- So excited!
- I feel like we've been
talking about this episode
since season one.
- One of my goals this trip
is to brush up on my Mandarin
because I have the Mandarin
skills of a four-year-old.
(Andrew chuckling)
My goal is to get it to a five-year-old
by the end of this trip.
- That's a very good goal.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
Dumpling Number One.
- We're going to see Ms.
Liu in her restaurant
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
How's that?
- Is that good?
- Good!
- We're gonna get some
fifty-cent pan-fried dumplings.
And it's--
- Have we ever had a price
so low on Worth It?
- No, we haven't!
That is a drastic price point.
(Andrew laughing)
(high-spirited piano music)
You've been making dumplings for 30 years.
I'm just curious what you think
makes the perfect dumpling.
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
- What types of buns do you serve here?
- And which one is your favorite?
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
(laughing)
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
- We've heard that the dough
of your buns is very delicious.
What makes it so special?
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
How many should we have?
(Inga laughing)
Oh, three?
- You know how you're actually in Taiwan?
- How?
- Dumplings.
- And motor scooter sounds.
- [Steven] It's a beautiful noise.
- So, not only are we having dumplings,
but we're also having...
- Soy milk.
So, we noticed you're actually making
your own soy milk here.
Can you tell us about
how you guys make that?
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
Cheers.
Oh!
Jeez!
- What?
I didn't know that's what soy
milk's supposed to taste like.
Kinda like a peanut butter drink.
- Uh-huh.
- Like that's how nutty
it tastes to me.
Inga, how's the soy milk?
- I'm like almost done with it. (laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- Really?
- I really like soy milk.
This is really good.
- It's like the first
time I had full-fat milk.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- You know?
Adam, try some soy milk.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Let's get to the buns.
Pork, cabbage, chive.
Look at the bottom crust.
It's like a little, "Hi! I'm crispy."
(Steven laughing)
Cheers.
(groovy music)
(Steven laughing)
The dough is so good.
What was the term for chewy?
- QQ.
- QQ?
Is that an actual term?
- Yeah.
- This is so QQ (Inga laughing)
- I don't know how to describe
the weight of it but...
- It's pleasantly plump.
- Pleasantly plump.
- Okay, the pork bun.
(Steven chuckling)
(groovy music)
Oh.
- Whoa!
- That's my favorite.
Adam, you wanna take a bite?
- You know my problem with burgers?
- [Adam] Oh!
(Steven and Andrew laughing)
- You're playing a game
of, like, Jenga and Tetris
as you're biting into it.
With the bun, you're not losing anything.
- Lastly, the cabbage.
I love the shape of this one.
It looks like a clam.
- This is 50 cents.
We just ate three dollars
of food, by the way.
- Okay, this one might
actually be my favorite.
Dammit!
(Steven laughing)
I don't live in Taiwan!
50 cents?
I don't even have to be hungry.
(Steven laughing)
It's just,
it'll be foolish not to.
- The pleasure you get
out of chewing really good
- Good dough.
- Bread.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- QQ!
I think you need to open this in America.
I can give you my address,
just open up shop next to me
'cause I need to eat this
on my way to work, please.
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
(Inga laughing)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
(Ms. Liu speaks in foreign language)
That was a dumpling.
Well, it's actually a
bao, but bao's a dumpling.
- QQ is my new favorite food terminology.
It's quite warm here in Taiwan.
- It's very warm.
- So, I think before
we have our next dumpling,
we need a refreshing treat.
We're in Taiwan.
What kind of treat should we have?
- Shaved ice!
- [Andrew] We're going to Showa Ice.
- [Steven] The Chinese name is
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
(cheerful music)
- This looks awesome.
This is one of your
favorite desserts, right?
- Not this specifically,
- Yeah.
- But shaved ice in general.
- Shaved ice generally.
- [Inga] So, there's two
types of shaved ice here,
the classic mango chunks
on top of milk shaved ice
and then chocolate
shaved ice with whiskey.
It's really good, but it
tastes really different.
- Ooh.
- I'm going full mango.
- Oh, wow.
This texture is very surprising.
- Oh, the mango!
Inga, get in here and try this mango.
This is like Garden of
Eden mango right here.
- This is so sweet.
(cheerful jazz music)
- Of course that tastes good.
You drink whiskey with ice?
- Yeah.
- And chocolate.
Chocolate works.
We're eating a food
that's cooked with steam,
and now we're eating ice.
So, we're just exploring all the,
I'm gonna call that the states of matter.
- Yeah.
- Do we have any chemists
in the room?
- Oh, excuse me.
- All right, chemist.
- Give me a fact!
- Dumpling fact!
It's not a dumpling fact.
- Oh?
- It's related to dumplings though.
Dumpling-related fact.
- Dumpling-related fact.
- Because most foods humans eat are soft,
the body and brain have
learned to like the novelty
of an opposing texture, like crunch.
Even after all that effort
to make a perfectly QQ dough,
it's still worth it to add
the crunch on the bottom.
- Back to the perfect food, man.
- All right, we're off to
our next dumpling spot.
- We're gonna go see Mr. Chen
in his steamed dumpling restaurant.
Inga, what's the name of it?
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
- Good work!
- Nice!
(lively piano music)
- How many dumplings do you think
your restaurant makes per day?
(Mr. Chen speaks in foreign language)
Wow.
- A day.
- 5000 a day.
- And they're all made by hand.
(Mr. Chen speaks in foreign language)
- What makes a really great dumpling?
- When customers come here,
are they only eating dumplings
or are they ordering other things as well?
(Mr. Chen speaks in foreign language)
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
So, we should order a
few more things as well?
(Mr. Chen speaks in foreign language)
(laughing)
That's right.
(cash register dinging)
We've built out our meal
with some extra stuff here.
- We have.
- Let's dumpling it up.
- They make 5000 of these,
a literal army of dumplings
in one day.
- Yeah.
It feels like I'm fighting
an army of dumplings
with my mouth.
- Boom.
Dip.
(string music)
- That's incredible.
- Oh, wow.
- Dumplings I've had in the past,
once it's steamed, it becomes
loose around the filling.
- Yeah.
- But these are tight and
dense and still juicy inside.
- So juicy.
- Let's do a side dish break.
- [Steven] I vote
century egg tofu madness.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
(Mr. Chen speaks in foreign language)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
(laughing)
- Wow!
- Whoa.
- [Steven] That's not what I was gonna do.
- [Andrew] Wow! (laughing)
- Okay.
- Yay!
- Wow, (Steven speaks in foreign language)
- Do you know what I realized?
- Yeah.
- Egg, nature's dumpling.
(Steven laughing)
- Wow.
- Whoo!
- Cheers, Steve.
- Cheers.
To a hundred years.
Oh, yeah.
Hold that up, hold that up!
- Yeah, that's what the egg--
- This is egg and you can see through it.
- It's very jelly.
- [Steven] All right, so, here we have
the vegetable dumpling.
- Watching them make these
dumplings was like magic.
They closed their hands
and when they open it,
there's a dumpling.
It's really like someone's
doing a card trick
in front of your eyes.
- Fun fact.
This is actually Inga's
grandmother's suggestion
of where to eat.
- Really?
- Yeah, my grandma was the one
who recommended this place to me.
- [Andrew] Good recommendation.
- It's so QQ.
(Andrew chuckling)
- Think about the amount of work
that's put into these
dumplings and how cheap it is.
That is the ultimate magic trick.
(Inga laughing)
- My mouth's so full!
- That pork dumpling.
- Like a Korean spa.
- Like a dry-cleaned shirt
steamed to perfection.
- Steamed to perfection.
- Our next dumpling is
also going to be steamed.
We're having the soup dumpling.
- [Steven] The Xiao Long Bao.
- That's right.
But before we do that, we're going to have
another Taiwanese dessert treat.
- SunnyHills Pineapple Cake.
It's one of my, oh my God,
it's one of my favorite places.
(playful piano music)
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
- Please enjoy.
- So, every time you come here,
even if you don't buy anything,
they will give this to
you, like a pineapple cake
with oolong tea.
- That's confidence.
That's, like, we know how good it is
because you're definitely gonna get it.
- Yes, and you will.
- Cheers.
(playful piano music)
Ooh-long, right?
- Good, right?
(laughing)
- Golly.
- Pineapple cakes are really good.
Buttery and flaky on the outside,
and then you get that really
fresh pineapple sweetness
and tartness.
- [Steven] Iconic.
- [Inga] Iconic.
- New York and cheesecakes.
Taiwan and pineapple cake.
- Yes, yes.
- Or something like that?
- Yes.
Smell it.
- Hmm.
- [Inga] Right?
- Mm, okay, I see.
I get it, yeah.
I've never had pineapple
jam-ified like this.
- So, you just pop the rest?
- Well, you might want to save to enjoy it
while you listen to this.
Dumpling fact!
(Steven laughing)
Sorry.
- What is fact in Mandarin?
- Oh!
Fact in--
- Could you say dumpling fact?
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
- Doesn't Andrew do language better?
- Say that again?
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
(Andrew speaks in foreign language)
(bleep)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
(Andrew loudly laughing)
- In 2013 and 2014, chef-turned-writer
Christopher St. Cavish
created a soup dumpling index,
measuring the thickness of the dough,
the soup volume, and the total
weight of each individual
xiao long bao at 52 different restaurants.
This data was then
calculated with the formula,
filling plus soup divided
by thickness of skin
times a hundred to assign
a score representing
the quality of structural
engineering in xiao long bao.
- Look, quadratic formula
was already hard enough.
All right, next stop.
We're going to a soup-er star--
(Andrew laughing)
- Oh!
- Soup dumpling spot, Din Tai Fung.
We're going to meet the bossman, Mr. Yang.
It originated here in Taiwan.
They, right now, at this very moment,
have 164 locations worldwide.
That's at this moment.
- That's wild.
- By tomorrow, there might be 180.
(Andrew laughing)
We don't know.
We're gonna go eat their
Truffle Soup Dumpling.
Truffle.
Have you had it before?
- Not truffle.
I'm not boujee.
(Andrew chuckling)
- I'm just gonna walk
away from that comment.
(heavy bass music)
(Mr. Yang speaks in foreign language)
- Was it always soup dumplings?
How do you get the soup
inside the dumpling?
- Yeah.
(Mr. Yang speaks in foreign language)
(laughing)
So, when it's steamed,
it becomes liquid-y?
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
(Mr. Yang speaks in foreign language)
What's important about
that pleating process?
(Mr. Yang speaks in foreign language)
How do you maintain such high
quality around the world?
(Mr. Yang speaks in foreign language)
- This is the Taiho IPA.
It's locally brewed,
and it has a really
strong flavor of fruits.
- Oh, the logo is great.
It's a tiger.
Cheers, Steven.
- Cheers.
- Mm that's good.
- That's, like,
almost cider.
- So, then, for the pork xiao long bao,
the most important part
is the soup inside.
It's sort of, like, the
soul of the xiao long bao.
So, we lift it up from the top,
we place it at the back--
(Steven and Andrew hollering)
of the spoon--
- Sorry, the bottom
just sagged down in a very satisfying way.
- Yeah.
- We poke a little hole inside
to let the broth come out.
- Oh, okay.
- Okay.
- And then please take a sip.
- You're gonna wait for
me or just eat alone?
Okay, great.
- I'm following instructions, Steven.
(Andrew exclaiming)
- Nice?
- Yes, nice.
- And then we can add
a little bit of ginger
with the sauce on top,
and then you can enjoy the
xiao long bao together.
- All right, together.
- I'm gonna wait for you
to drink your--
Yeah.
- [Steven] I'm not good at..
how did you poke that so well?
(Andrew laughing)
- Would you need some help?
(laughing)
- Cheers, Steven.
- Cheers.
(lips smacking)
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's really good.
- [Steven] It's almost cloth-like--
- Like a fabric.
- The bottom of it.
- The broth has, like, a sweetness to it.
It's so good.
Do people ever eat it in one bite?
- Yes, they do.
But please be careful
because it's really hot.
- Right.
- Okay.
- Sometimes, you just gotta fly too close
to the sun though, so...
- I feel like I wanna feel
it burst into my mouth.
- It is hot.
(laughing)
We've mentioned it so much in this video,
but I really have to
bring it back to the QQ.
- Even though the dough is so thin,
it still is very satisfying.
- How do you attain that kind of texture
in, like, a film sheet.
- Adam, can you try this, please?
(laughing)
- Oh, that's good.
- Yeah, it's really good.
- This is our truffle
and pork xiao long bao.
- Why do a truffles dumpling?
(Mr. Yang speaks in foreign language)
(cash register dings)
- [Andrew] Cleanse my palate.
(perky music)
- Before we get into the eating,
(Andrew laughing)
I do have to point out the pleating
- Yeah.
- On this dumpling.
They're beautiful.
- Oh, yes.
(slurping sounds)
Oh!
What?
(Andrew chuckling)
- [Steven] Boujee cheers!
- Oh, sorry.
(laughing)
These are awesome.
Okay.
Last season, we ate soup
that had truffle in it.
We learned that it has to be
activated by heat and fat.
- Right.
- So, the truffle in a soup
dumpling totally makes sense.
It really says something about this dough
that even though it's so thin,
you still get that QQ.
- [Steven] It's impossibly thin.
- Common complaint about our show
is that we always just
put truffle in stuff
to make it more expensive.
- And we see you comment
section, we see you.
- But these are about three
US dollars per dumpling,
which is expensive, but
for the taste of truffle,
how nice this is, I'd say that's worth it.
(laughing)
Show title, watch out. (laughing)
- They're doing truffle right.
- Yeah.
They're not doing it wrong.
(Steven laughing)
Adam, you wanna see if
they're doing it right?
(laughing)
(Adam chuckling)
- [Steven] So, we're here
at Raohe Night Market
because Inga suggested that we come
and eat their stinky tofu.
- The smell around the
stall is quite stinky,
but once it's fried, it
is much more subdued.
Cheers, Steven.
- Cheers.
- So juicy!
Holy crap!
Speaking of soup dumpling,
there's a soup tofu.
- Try stinky tofu.
- Okay, so before we get
to our Worth It winners,
what was your favorite
thing in this episode
that was not a dumpling?
- My favorite thing was
the fire hydrant soy milk.
(Andrew laughing)
at the (in foreign language) place.
The visuals of that are just astounding.
- My favorite thing was getting
dressed like a scientist
at Din Tai Fung's central kitchen.
We went to this airlock
that blew all the dust
and hair off of us.
And we got to see some really cool
behind-the-scenes stuff.
So, Steven, which dumpling
was the most worth it to you
at its given price?
- My Worth It winner today
goes to the pan-fried dumpling
at (in foreign language).
The value was incredible there.
The dumplings were amazing.
- The cabbage bun at that
location was very nearly
my Worth It winner, but
I have to give it to the
steamed pork dumplings at Location Two.
Like my fantasy of a
dumpling is that dumpling.
Inga, who's your Worth It winner?
- I don't know.
It's so hard.
I wanna say two because
it's my grandma's favorite,
but I think it's honestly one.
- [Andrew] Annie?
(laughing)
Adam says his winner's Din Tai Fung.
Next week, soup.
That's right.
Soup, again.
So soon, you say?
Trust us.
Taiwan may be the perfect
place to have soup.
- Yes, so excited.
There's so many soups.
We have so many soups.
It's gonna be great.
- So many soups.
(Inga laughs)
(groovy music)
- "Worth It: Taiwan" is back.
- "Worth It" chicken.
Is that a chicken?
- Yeah.
- Kind of.
- It's a rooster.
Which is a chicken.
- Is that a chicken?
- No, that's a pigeon.
We're here in Taiwan's
garden night market.
We just picked up our chicken treats.
Tomorrow the journey begins.
We're going to three cities
for three acts of chicken,
ending in a chicken finale
like you've never seen before.
- Bok, bok, bish.
Leggo.
- Mm!
It's like a pancake.
- Today on "Worth It," we're going to be
trying three chicken dishes
at three drastically
different price points
to find out which one is the
most worth it at its price.
- So we're eating chicken,
but our first chicken
is actually a soup.
I know we just finished a soup video,
but that's just how many
soups there are here.
You can't escape the soup.
We're off to see the Chen
family at Walking Su,
where we're going to be trying
their sesame oil chicken.
- What is that in Mandarin, Inga?
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
(Steven speaks in foreign language)
- Okay, I'm excited to eat some chicken.
- Let's do it.
(xylophone music)
- Tell us about how this
business got started.
(speaks in foreign language)
So this is a family business.
What do each of you do?
(speaks in foreign language)
Do you find it easy working together?
- [Steven] Sesame oil chicken.
Is that dish a classic Taiwanese dish?
(speaks in foreign language)
(laughs)
- What are those herbs
adding to this dish?
(speaks in foreign language)
(cash register dings)
- [Steven] This looks incredible.
- We're got a couple
additional accoutrements here.
The Thai basil sauce, the
spicy fermented bean paste,
and sticky rice.
All right, let's taste the broth.
Sesame oil chicken.
Mm.
Delightful nuttiness of the sesame oil.
- Yes.
Super nutty.
- Super.
- It's got this hearty feel to it.
- Oh, yeah, this is hearty as (beep).
How was that?
- So incredibly juicy and tender and, ugh.
I'm going to smell the Thai basil,
because that's their specialty here.
- Whoa!
Smells like pesto.
- Yeah.
What?
- That is awesome.
That is like a salad dressing
to dip your soup into.
Adam, you gotta try the
chicken in the Thai basil.
- Ooh.
(Andrew laughs)
- Want to try some rice?
- Oh, yes.
- Chicken, Steven.
- Cheers.
- The thing I keep getting
blown away by in Taiwan,
I go to a meal expecting one thing,
and then there's always
all this bonus stuff
that just blows my
expectations out of the water.
- Yeah, and even when they
first started this restaurant,
this was a bonus dish.
- Right.
- Right, that's crazy.
- This was a free thing.
- So there's a lot of
herbs added to this soup.
It tastes like an elixir.
It just washes away all
of the pain in your body.
Achy back, I got a soup for that.
Tired eyes.
- Soup for that.
- My foot hurts.
- Throw some soup on there.
- It's all the same soup.
It's very convenient.
Adam, you want to get some of this soup?
I'm pretending like Adam's over here,
even though he's over there.
- Hi.
(laughs)
- So our next chicken
location is in Taipei,
but first we're going to
take a countryside detour.
- Yep, that's right.
We're going to a scallion farm in Yilan.
And we're going to be making
our own scallion pancakes.
Not just cooking them.
We're going to pick them ourselves.
- Scallions, yeah.
- Yes.
- It's a chicken episode,
it's a soup episode,
and now it's a pancake episode.
(upbeat trumpet music)
- What you see in front of you
here is a scallion pancake,
but rewind three hours.
What did we do?
- [Andrew] We're in this unique valley
where you get different temperature winds
at different times of day,
which create a nice perfect
humidity for growing scallions.
So today we've picked
a bunch of scallions,
cleaned them up, chopped
them, cried a little bit,
and then learned how to
make scallion pancakes.
And here we have it,
the spoils of our toils.
- Cheers!
- Mm.
- Oh, yo.
- Yo.
Okay, this is one of the best
things I've eaten so far.
You know what time it is now?
Time for a Taiwan food fact.
The concept of "xiao
chi," meaning little eats,
is popular in Taiwan,
basically meaning snacking
throughout the day, often on
street food, between meals.
- Of course, yeah.
In Taiwan, if you only eat
three meals in one day,
you're just doing it wrong.
- We're actually on our
way to a snack shop next.
Inga, where are we going?
(Inga speaks in foreign language)
We're going to see Reebok and Julia
and try their fried chicken.
(solemn piano music)
- What makes a perfect
fried chicken to you guys?
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Andrew] So what makes your Taiwanese
fried chicken unique?
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Steven] What do you
recommend that we drink
with the fried chicken?
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Andrew] What?
- This is not what I was expecting.
- You ready, Steven?
- I'm ready.
- This is called dining al fresco.
- So we've ordered the
recommended sparkling wine.
Apparently, you only
order by the bottle here.
- I like that.
- It's my speed.
- Let's go.
Cheers.
- How awesome is this?
This is some riviera (beep).
- We got to eat this while
it's hot, so let's go.
Ooo.
It smells so good.
- Oh, it's so fragrant.
The garlic, the onion, this basil.
The meat inside is so soft.
- It's very pleasing.
- Very pleasing.
Like brûléed marshmallows.
Seriously.
- Oh man.
- It's wild.
I thought QQ was only for dumplings.
- Whoa.
(Andrew laughs)
- It's so soft.
- It's almost like chicken nugget-esque.
- You know what's crazy about this?
We've eaten fried chicken in Minneapolis,
where the restaurant thought,
"You know what's actually
the best drink to have with fried chicken?
Sparkling wine."
And here we are in Taiwan,
and this restaurant had the same idea.
- I see, I see.
- If there's a restaurant
on either side of the world
that is doing the same
thing, it must be great.
(speaks in foreign language)
- I'm scared to eat
this, because I'm scared
of how much I'll like it.
- [Andrew] Pork knuckle and radish cake.
- Wow.
Ooo.
Oh, man.
- Watch out, you're going
to push me off my stool.
- Radish cake is a classic dim sum dish.
I've eaten this every time I go out.
You know, they bring around the carts
and they're all steamed, right?
It's still hot but it doesn't have
that break-through-the-crunch
texture that this has.
- You could maybe liken
it to a potato pancake.
That's so good.
- Yeah it's crazy.
- Yeah.
How should we eat the pork knuckle?
- [Chef] By hand.
- [Andrew] By hand?
Just like an apple?
- [Chef] Mm-hmm.
- Okay.
Kind of looks like a donut.
- Oh!
Yours does.
- Mine does.
- Cheers.
- Oh my god.
This is like a pork donut.
Wow.
(Steven laughs)
- So this is actually
cartilage, but it feels like fat
with how loosey-goosey it is.
- The gelatin is the
jelly of this pork donut.
- Right.
- And to wash it down, sparkling wine.
- Oh, thank goodness for this.
- How awesome is this?
- Thank you.
- This was really good.
(speaks in foreign language)
- We are at the Beijing hotel,
where they serve a boba croissant.
Yes, you heard me right.
Boba croissant.
(imitates whooshing)
- We got the matcha,
tiramisu and the milk tea.
Which one do you want?
- My gut is going toward matcha,
but I'm going against my gut
and going for the tiramisu.
- I actually knew that you
were going to pick that one,
because it has gold flake on it.
(Steven laughs)
All right, I'll go milk tea.
Very satisfying to pick up.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Are you going to bite into it?
- Yeah.
- Or open it up?
- I'm going to bite into it.
- Oh.
(Steven gasps)
This is just all of the textures.
This is nice.
It's satisfyingly squishy.
- I think there's a word for that, QQ.
- Ready for a Taiwan food fact, Steven?
- Taiwan food fact!
Taiwan food fact.
- Um.
- Up until the 1960s, the most
common Taiwanese breakfast
was rice or congee.
Buns emerged as a popular
Taiwanese food in the 1960s
when U.S. trade introduced
wheat into the Taiwanese diet.
- Shouldn't that fact go
in the dumpling episode
that we did?
- Well, it was more about breakfast.
I just wanted an excuse
to talk about congee,
because it's just a nice, savory thing
to have for breakfast.
- This is a very good croissant.
- Yeah.
- I got a cake.
- [Steven] Oh, my.
- [Andrew] This boba croissant
is part of a boba festival.
- Boba fest.
- And Inga's got the crown
jewel of the festival.
And now it's time to
take a little train ride.
- QQ.
(Andrew laughs)
You want to hear my boba rap?
- Yeah.
- How do you like your boba?
- Eat it like a cobra.
- Yeah.
- My name is Yoda.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- [Steven] And I like yoga.
- Now dab.
- Never.
- This is a train water
bottle that they sell
on the train.
(imitates train chugging)
So once we get done with this
guy, we'll be in Taichung
and we'll be eating at our
final chicken location.
- We're going to go meet
RuiHong at Yan Xiang Lou
to have Beggar's Chicken.
(uplifting orchestral music)
- What kind of cuisine is the food here?
(speaks in foreign language)
- Tell us about this dish,
the Beggar's Chicken.
(speaks in foreign language)
- What happened to the beggar?
(laughs)
(speaks in foreign language)
I hope so.
- [Andrew] Why bake the chicken in clay?
(speaks in foreign language)
How do we get the chicken
out from the clay?
(speaks in foreign language)
Which one of us gets to do it?
- [Steven] I'll do the hammering,
you do the hammer time.
- What?
You just automatically assume
that you get to hammer.
(speaks in foreign language)
- You can both do it.
- Two hammers?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Great.
- Resolved.
Ooh, thank you.
Cheers to our final meal in Taiwan.
- Oh, no!
- I know.
- Cheers.
- Since this is our last meal in Taiwan,
we're blowing it out.
- [Steven] Let's do it.
- I saw a little sneak peek
of what's coming upstairs.
It's going to blow you away.
So this is winter melon.
- [Steven] Whoa.
- Wow.
- What?
Look at it coming out,
pouring on the fish's head.
- These look too real.
Look at the scales on these guys.
- Honestly, every time
I've seen a koi fish,
I've thought they looked
like a tasty fish.
Cheers, Steven.
Fish kiss.
That's a good dumpling.
- Aw, fish super good.
- This looks like in
"Hook," when Robin Williams
is imagining the food.
Have you seen this movie?
It's all vibrant colors.
Do yourself a favor, go watch "Hook."
You'll have a delightful time.
You'll be reminded of this moment.
- I'm going pink for my hair.
We might as well have just
shot all three episodes here.
- Much like the origin myth,
first we're eating like an emperor,
and then we're taking a journey
to discover the chicken.
- Food is all about storytelling.
Well, and taste.
(Andrew laughs)
But also storytelling.
(dramatic orchestral music)
(Steven laughs)
- Ohh.
Hey, oh.
- Okay.
What?
- Yes.
- What?
- [Inga] You guys can go up now.
- Hammer time?
- Okay.
- All right, Steven.
I'm nervous.
- I am scared, too.
- [Both] One, two, three!
(clay shatters)
- Wow.
- Nice!
- Looks like chocolate.
- Smells like dirt.
- Dirt.
(laughs)
We just hatched our chicken dinner.
It was very dino egg-like.
- [Both] Mm.
- Wow.
Chicken cheers.
- Chicken cheers.
- Oh, that's good.
- What?
That is so soft.
- Some people say chicken's a boring meal.
I would say those people haven't had it--
- Deep-fried, baked in clay.
- Stuffed with pork and aromatics.
- There's pork in the chicken?
- Yeah.
- [Inga] So now she's just adding a sauce.
I think it's an oyster sauce slurry.
- Oh.
That tastes like my mom's fried rice.
Whoa, that was weird.
- "Mom?"
(laughs)
You know what this chicken is?
It's a time capsule.
For flavor.
Buried under dirt, much
like a regular time capsule.
But it's also a dish--
- From the Ming dynasty.
Is there a letter written in there?
Like, "Dear diary, do I still taste good?"
- Yeah.
- Very soft.
At its core, this dish is just a plate
of really nice chicken.
So simple, so perfect.
We're going to take it back
into artistry land now,
if that's okay with you.
- Let's do it.
What is going on right now?
- Yeah, dude.
(Andrew laughs)
Looks like a scene from
"Nightmare Before Christmas."
This is too beautiful not to share.
I think we should get everybody in here
and we all take a bite.
Who wants a swan, who wants a pumpkin?
Cheers, everybody.
- Cheers.
- What?
Oh my god.
It's red bean.
- Why?
- Wow.
- Not "why."
Why not?
Worth it.
Beggar's Chicken.
You know they say beggars
can't be choosers,
but beggars can be chicken.
That was quite an experience.
Steven, before we get to
our "Worth It" winners,
what was your favorite
thing that wasn't one
of the highlight foods in
this "Worth It" episode.
- The Pork Knuckle at
Chu Zha Xiaoshi Dian.
Mm.
(hand thuds)
- That's the knuckle.
- It was so good, I contemplated
eating my own knuckles.
What was your favorite thing?
- Honestly, the hard ass
rain while we were filming
location two.
We had a typhoon barely
graze us, but we still got
some awesome hard rain, which I love.
- Which chicken was the
most worth it to you?
- My "Worth It" winner,
Walking Su sesame oil chicken.
- [Steven] Woo.
- If that chicken had
been in the soup episode,
it would have won that episode, too.
- Wow.
- Comforting, exciting, inexpensive.
It was wonderful.
Who was your "Worth It" winner?
- Okay.
Walking Su, totally new experience.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Yan Xiang Lou.
If you could eat with your
eyes, that place would have won.
But, because that pork
knuckle was so effing good,
my "Worth It" winner must
go to Chu Zha Xiaoshi Dian.
- Inga, "Worth It" winner.
- Two, Chu Zha Xiaoshi Dian.
With Reebok and Julia.
- [Steven] Annie?
- [Annie] The swan.
- Adam, who's your "Worth It" winner?
- [Adam] Fried chicken.
- Oo, the fried chicken.
Very good choice.
- All right.
That's a wrap on "Worth It: Taiwan."
- Very special thank you to
the Taiwan Tourism Bureau,
that helped us out
tremendously with this trip.
Couldn't have been here without them.
- All right, let's get out of here.
Bye!
(upbeat groovy music)
- Welcome back.
- Welcome back, Steven.
We're doing another three episode burst
before the new year rolls in.
You might be wondering
why we're not driving.
Say hi, Devon.
Devon's up front driving
because we're picking up
our special co-star today.
He's an avid fan of the show,
from River Forest, Illinois.
His name is Jackson, and
his visit is made possible
by Make-A-Wish.
- [Steven] What's up?
Nice to meet you
(parents laughing)
Hi, guys!
- Hey.
- You ready to go?
- Yes.
- [Steven] All right.
(grunts)
There's Adam, say hi.
- Hey.
(Andrew laughs)
- Welcome to the car, Jackson.
- It's the worth automobile.
- That's right.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
I'm the pun master on this show.
- [Steven] I like it.
- But thank you Jackson for joining us
on our double cheeseburger episode today.
- Thank you for having me.
- You flew all the way out from Illinois.
- Yes.
- The Midwest,
I like you already.
- Should we do the Today on Worth It?
- You don't know how to do that?
- Today on "Worth It", we're having
three double cheeseburgers
at three addresses
at three different price points
to see which one is worth it.
- The most worth it.
- [Together] The most worth it.
- At its given price point.
- So that's at least six patties.
- Are you prepared?
- I'm hungry.
- Good
- So the first place we're going to
is called Burgers Never Say Die.
We're gonna see Shawn.
- This is a smash burger joint.
I love Super Smash, the
game, Ultimate, and all.
You play Ultimate?
- Yes
- Ooh, who's your main?
- (chuckling) Oh my God.
- Donkey Kong.
- Okay, okay, I'm a Ness man.
- You're bringing all
the co-host attributes
that Steven wants in
me, but I don't possess.
- Hey, do you watch the NBA?
- Yes.
(all exclaiming)
- That's what I'm talking about.
- So your menu starts with the regular,
and the regular has two patties.
- Yes
- Why is that?
- I like double cheeseburgers.
That's what I grew up eating.
It also works because it's a smash patty.
- [Andrew] And tell us
what a smash burger is?
- [Shawn] It's cooked on a
flat top, at very high heat,
and you just smash it down
there, so it sears to the griddle
and the whole process probably
takes a minute or less.
- [Jackson] What makes
a really good burger?
- [Shawn] It's so subjective,
like personally, for me,
I like burgers cooked on the griddle.
- [Jackson] What does the griddle add?
- [Shawn] You get flavor that's
been there, the seasoning
from the food items other than burgers.
- [Andrew] What drew you to
making burgers specifically?
- My wife and I, we were
always really into burgers
and got into the food scene of LA.
Bringing together all the burgers we ate,
I thought, I wanna try
making this burger myself.
I started in my backyard
with no intention of opening a restaurant.
For a couple weeks, I was
just begging people to come
and try the burger;
friends, coworkers, whoever.
And then, some people approached me,
asking if I wanted to open a restaurant.
And throughout my whole life,
I usually just jump in,
and I thought, let's give this
a shot and see what happens.
- We have a sign right here
that says, "always order two".
Why?
- It's an ode to the backyard.
People would order one,
and they would regret it
and then there would be a long
line or we had sold out, so.
- Is two still doable?
- I recommend two for you, yeah.
- What about you, do you do two?
- I do two, I've eaten
like six in one day, so.
(laughing)
- Oh my goodness.
- I mean we're gonna do six probably,
over the course of this day, for us,
so why not start with two?
- (sighs) Here we go.
(cash register dings)
- [Andrew] All right,
Jackson, take it away.
- Worth-it, Double Cheeseburger, take one.
- Nice.
- That was perfect.
That was better than I usually do.
Take two.
(clattering) (laughing)
So that Burgers Never Say Die,
they also have soft serve ice cream.
Insider pro tip;
you get your soft serve in a
cup, order a soda on the side,
and then mix it for your own float.
What are the correct
proportions for a float?
Does anybody know?
- The whole bottle.
- It's a feel.
- Jackson's got classic root beer float.
This is Steven's--
- [Steven] I got chocolate--
- And a blueberry root beer.
Okay, when, when, when, when.
Cheers!
- Cheers!
How do you eat this?
- Who thought of floats?
- Ooh!
- Pour some soda on some ice cream?
That's like some,
the-parents-aren't-home,
mischief (all laughing).
- [All] Cheers.
- The fries!
- Taste like McDonald's.
- Taste like McDonald's, yeah.
- So these fries are fried in beef tallow.
Apparently this is what
McDonald's tasted like
way back in the day,
before they switched to a vegetable oil.
Staying true to their motto,
we've two burgers for each
of us except for you Jackson,
because this is your first
time on one of these rodeos,
I don't wanna do that to you.
- Whoa.
- It looks the way a fast food
burger looks in a commercial,
but this is how it is in real life.
- [Jackson] It smells good.
- Great bun smell.
Did you think you'd have to wait this long
before you actually get to take a bite?
- Can I point out one
more physical attribute
of this burger before we bite into it?
Sorry, Jackson.
Look at the way it's like a lattice.
- [Andrew] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Crispy?
- Very crispy.
But you can almost see through the meat.
- [Andrew] Like a spider's web.
- [All] Cheers!
- Oh, man.
Wow!
- It's crunchy too
- It's really crunchy.
- Yeah.
- It's the essence of burger.
There's nothing extra.
There's not like strange
sauces or condiments.
- Oh man.
- This might be the best
burger I've ever had.
- Oh man.
- Like truly.
- Would you agree with that?
- Yes.
- This is one of my favorite ones.
- Swallow your food.
(Jackson and Steven laughing)
- Next burger, here we go.
- You would definitely be
satisfied by one of these,
but you're gonna want two.
- I do agree.
Order two.
What am I doing with my life now?
I'm only slightly lactose-intolerant,
so low levels of cheese, that's fine.
Are you lactose-intolerant at all?
- No.
- You're a lucky person.
Oh, we had ice cream, too.
What am I doing? (all laughing)
- [Andrew] Jackson, what do you think
about the part of the
show where Adam eats?
- He takes really large bites.
(laughing)
- I'm gonna finish mine before you.
- Of course.
I don't know if I could do that.
- What a cheeseburger.
- [Jackson and Steven] That was insane.
- We keep talking at the same time.
- Oh.
- Twins!
- Look who is simpatico.
So before our next double cheeseburger,
we're actually gonna get
another double cheeseburger.
We're going to this French restaurant
in West Hollywood, called Tesse.
I saw on Instagram, that
for National Burger day,
they made, we're just gonna call it
a special dessert burger.
We reached out, and
the pastry chef, Sally,
so kindly agreed to remake
it, but double this time.
This might be the most visually
appealing burger of the day.
(charming old school music)
- Close your eyes.
- Okay.
- Man, this is gonna blow you away.
Three, two, one, reveal!
(Steven and Jackson exclaiming)
- [Andrew] It's very realistic.
- Dude, is that a strawberry?
- [Jackson and Andrew] Yes.
- [Andrew] Two macaroons,
chocolate ganache,
mango passion fruit cheese,
strawberry slices, shiso leaf,
and a raspberry jelly for the ketchup.
- Wow.
If you did not tell me that was dessert,
I would not have guessed it.
- [All] Cheers!
- [Steven] How to eat this?
(mumbling)
- It's actually really good.
I mean it's chocolate and
fruit, what's not to like?
- It's sweet and bitter at the same time.
- [Steven] That's the nosh.
- The tasting notes coming off of Jackson.
This isn't your first time, is it?
- No.
- All right, I retire today,
you can have the--
- Do you know what time it is now?
- Yes.
Oh, you're asking me or Jackson?
- If you didn't know, I'd be concerned.
- Fact time.
- That's right, double cheeseburger fact.
- Double cheeseburger fact.
- One minute.
(all laughing)
Double cheeseburger fact.
- Bob's Big Boy, is credited with selling
the first double cheeseburger in 1937.
The chain's original name was Bob's Pantry
but after the double cheeseburger,
dubbed the Big Boy, was invented,
the restaurant changed its name
to boast its famous burger.
The double cheeseburger became so famous,
they changed their restaurant name.
- [Adam] What about renaming this show?
- Whoa.
It would probably be
called, Adam's Silent Bite.
- No, Adam's Big Bite.
- Adam's Big Bite.
Yes!
For our next double cheeseburger,
we're on our way to see Frederick and Max,
at Burgerlords, in Highland Park.
Similar to this double cheeseburger,
this next double cheeseburger's
made without meat.
- I've never had a veggie
cheeseburger before.
- Curveball for the episode.
- I'm scared and excited.
- Scared and excited is a
good place to be with food.
Tell us what kind of
restaurant Burgerlords is.
- The way I think of it, it's
kind of a bizzaro version
of a traditional fast food restaurant.
You're used to a frozen
garden burger, portobello.
This is the opposite, where
everything is vegan, vegetarian,
except the beef burger.
- Do you think you're more popular
with traditional beef cheeseburgers
or with the vegetarian and vegan crowd?
- Honestly it's like 50-50.
- Yeah?
- Yeah we look at it
every week.
- [Steven] How did you guys develop
the recipe for this patty?
- [Max] Everything kind of has its role.
The barley for chewiness, and
cashews give it a nice crunch.
We're roasting all the eggplants,
slicing up the other vegetables.
Those get sauteed with all
the spices on the flat top.
Cooking barley in a rice
cooker, with kambu and miso,
roasting nuts, garbanzo beans, cashews,
and then it all goes into
one batch, and just mixed up.
- [Fred] Once it's cold, it settles,
and then we're balling it
like a traditional burger.
We roll it in Panko, then we patty it out,
so the Panko when it's cooking
gives it a kinda crispy edge.
- [Max] Helps keep the patty
from burning on the grill, too.
- [Fred] All of the work
comes at the beginning,
so we can push it out really fast.
On average, I mean our tickets,
are like five to 10 minutes.
It's like neo-fast food.
- [Max] It feels like fast
food, it looks like it
on the exterior, but in the
kitchen, we're cooking all day.
- [Steven] Now that you've
explained all of this,
it feels like a burger joint
is the hardest thing
to do for vegetarians.
Like why did you wanna
tackle a burger joint?
- You know, there's the nostalgia.
You know, it's the experience of a diner,
a fast food restaurant, having
fries and eating a burger.
It was also to create
something that we didn't think
really existed here.
You know, when we grew up,
there was a lot of times we felt left out,
so we wanted to make
sure that everyone felt
they had a good option here.
(cash register dings)
- So to round out our experience,
we also got the tofu
nuggets and french fries,
lord-of-the-fries style.
- Lord of the fries, that's a good pun.
Have you read "Lord of the Fries" yet?
(all laughing)
- Oh God.
- We can't take you anywhere.
- Cheers.
- Ah, this is good.
We need napkins.
- Oh my goodness.
For the first time in my life,
I have somebody who is also a messy eater.
Look at that.
- [Jackson] Cheese crust.
- [Andrew] It's got the cheese crust.
- Cheers.
- [Steven] Veggie bumps.
- This is good.
- Wow.
- It doesn't taste like plants at all.
It tastes like real beef.
- It's hot, cheesy, juicy,
meaty, and yet there's no meat.
So when you think, "Man, I could really go
"for a burger right now."
Does this satisfy that feeling?
- 100%
(laughing)
- Are you gonna finish that thing Steven?
- I'm trying to.
- Put a little hot sauce on there.
- Ooh!
- Yeah, hot sauce me.
You know what, that's really good.
It's a nice little kick.
It really brightens the
flavor of the burger.
- Oh, it has a good
kick to it, that's good.
- It is like I'm in a
different universe right now.
Vegetarian food, in this
universe, is the norm.
- It does kind a feel like
we're in a Twilight Zone set,
a little bit, just like
transported back in time,
but to an alternate reality
where everybody's a vegetarian,
and you know what?
Pretty good.
You ever watch Twilight Zone?
- [Andrew] Wow, that was a good bite.
- This is so good.
- Life blowing.
- Life blowing (laughing)
- Not just mind blowing
- Life blowing
- Life.
Oh my gosh, guys, I'm on patty number ten.
(laughing)
- That was eight.
- Oh, sorry, eight.
- It was eight.
Yeah.
- I can't count anymore.
That's how many patties I've had.
- Before we go to our last
burger, it's time for one more--
- Burger fact.
- [Andrew] Double cheeseburger fact!
- Oh dang it. (laughs)
- Would you like to read the fact today?
- Sure.
The price of the Big Mac
when it debuted nationwide was 49 cents.
- 49 cents?
So you're telling me I
could go to a McDonald's
with two quarters and come back
with a Big Mac and a penny?
- Yeah, in the 60s, when it debuted.
- Oh, sorry.
- [Adam] That happened a long--
- Back in the 60s.
- Back in the 60s, right.
- We're on our way to Petit Trois,
where we're gonna see Chef Ludo,
and his double cheeseburger
called, The Big Mec.
- And what is on this Big Mec?
- Well, it's a French
Restaurant, so sauce.
- Petit Trois, it's a
classic French restaurant.
The design and the food is very French.
- And so you have this burger.
How does that fit into that classic menu?
- In France, we eat a lot of steak hache,
you know, is a patty, so I
decided to just do a burger,
like what Americans like, you know?
And look like a burger, too.
- [Jackson] What makes
a really good burger?
- [Ludo] A burger needs
to be crispy and juicy.
When I eat a steak or any
meat, that's what I want.
I want the meat to be crispy
- It's called the Big Mec,
styled after the Big Mac,
of course, right?
- Of course, yeah yeah, of course.
Mec, in France, means guys,
(speaks in foreign language)
French food is all about the sauce,
so what's very important
for me to have my burger
in the plate, swimming in the sauce,
like when you eat a
steak, so I decided to do
a classic French sauce, called Bordelaise,
beef stock with a lot of
shallot and a red wine sauce.
We take like eight hour to do,
then after we have aged cheddar cheese.
How do you know if I'm going
to put aged cheddar cheese
or American cheese?
Because I love American cheese.
- Really?
- Oh I love it.
- You love American cheese?
- Oh we don't like American cheese?
Guys, come on.
- Some people don't.
- When I think about French
cuisine, I think fine dining,
or I think like kind of--
- Foufou?
- [Steven] Yeah, a little bit,
I mean this burger is not
what comes to mind, right?
- My job as a chef is also
to cook what people want.
And it's fun to mix American
food with French cuisine.
I recommend to eat the
burger with a fork and knife.
Very French foufou, like you say.
- You said that, not me.
- So it is fork and knife?
- In France, we eat our
burger with a fork and knife.
Okay guys, sorry, yeah we do.
(cash register dings)
- [Steven] There it is.
- It's really unlike any
burger I've ever seen before.
- Look at how it's plated.
- [Jackson] It's in a pool of sauce.
- Yeah, it looks like a
lily pad in a murky pond.
- [Steven] Will you do the honors?
- Oh man, oh okay.
- [Steven] Everybody on the internet
is going to watch you cut this in half.
- We're losing traction here.
- Oh, god. (laughs)
- [Andrew] This is a $25 cheeseburger
that you're just hacking through.
- [Steven] Double.
- Stab through the whole
thing to secure your bite.
What?
Oh god. (all laughing)
- I regret saying that I would
be okay sharing a burger.
I'm gonna cheers?
- Cheers!
- And then I'm gonna mop up some sauce.
- It's magical.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, boy.
- Wow.
Oh man, that sauce.
- That sauce.
- Is incredible.
- The patty is so crispy.
- It's juicy and crispy at the same time.
- Okay, if I were to
go back to Burgerlords,
that was everything I want in a burger,
but it's vegetarian.
- This is everything I didn't
know I wanted in a burger.
- Exactly, I don't think I've
had a sauce like this before,
that is so rich and yet tantalizing.
- Yes, the sourness just
makes you crave more.
- Yes, it does.
- Jackson's like, keep talking
while I eat the rest of this burger.
- (chuckling) He is destroying our burger.
- Is this what you thought
an expensive burger
would look like on Worth It?
- No, I thought it would look fancier.
Most expensive burgers, like
your episode with Keith,
it was a lot of ingredients,
like foie gras and lobster.
This one just has beef
and cheese and a sauce.
It's so simple that you
don't need anything else.
How is it?
- I can see why you'd
use a fork and knife.
(laughing)
- So how do you feel?
- Food coma.
- Food coma?
- So now's the time.
You know what time it is.
- Double cheeseburger dance time.
Go!
(laughing)
Double cheeseburger, hey!
Oh!
- Before we get to our Worth It winners,
what was your favorite thing today
that wasn't a double cheeseburger?
- The dessert at Tesse.
- Oh yeah.
- That was good.
- You just stole my answer.
- My favorite thing today that
wasn't a double cheeseburger
was our co-star Jackson.
- Aw.
- And that fact that I
didn't have to eat alone
with Steven one more time.
I think we'll start
with you today, Steven.
Which double cheeseburger
was most worth it to you,
at its given price?
- Burgers Never Say Die.
The texture of the patty
was what I try to accomplish
when I add chips to my burgers.
Crunchy, crispy, juicy.
- Hold on, rewind this back.
You put potato chips
on your cheeseburgers?
- Yeah, great double cheeseburger.
But I gotta say my worth-it winner
just barely goes to the Burgerlords.
- [Andrew] Oh the vegetarian
double cheeseburger.
- That redefined what a
double cheeseburger could be.
Next up, we got Andrew.
(Andrew groans)
- I love all of these places.
Burgers Never Say Die, probably
the best straightforward
cheeseburger I've ever had.
Burgerlords, I think that's
where I'd go if I wanted
to hang out with people.
Am I gonna say my worth
it winner is Petit Trois?
I think I am.
When I think about it, I start salivating.
I think it's the Bordelaise sauce.
- Did you see that coming?
- No.
- I thought he was gonna
choose Burgers Never Say Die.
- Yeah, me too
- Look.
Obviously, they were all great burgers.
- Okay, before I say my worth it winner,
how could you not pick the last one?
I mean you're the hype beast of food.
- (laughing) What?
- You're a very fancy boy, you know?
- Hot dog, you picked the high-priced one.
Steak, high priced.
- Wow.
If you actually go back
and tally the ones I pick
the high-priced one,
though, it's not that often.
- Sushi and burger.
- Okay, all right, I'm out of here.
- Jackson knowledge of the show
is coming back to haunt us.
- Just kidding, I love you, buddy.
- I love you too, bro.
- All right, Jackson.
- Okay.
- No more beating around the bush.
Who's your Worth It winner?
- [Jackson] So the veggie burger,
it was a new experience for me.
I'm going to start
ordering veggie burgers,
so Burgerlords is my Worth It winner.
- What?
(Jackson and Steven exclaim in excitement)
Are you kidding me?
That was a good fake out.
Adam, who's your Worth It winner?
- [Adam] Burgers Never Say Die.
- Annie, who's your Worth It winner?
- Burgers Never Say Die.
- All right, we've got a good mix here.
But all we know for sure
is that Andrew lost today.
- I did not lose.
- This has been quite the journey.
- Thank you for having me.
- No, thank you for flying
all the way out here.
- It was worth it.
- What?
Show name, watch out.
(laughing)
This Worth It winner decision
is going to haunt me forever.
- So you wanna change it?
- I take it back, it's--
(upbeat music)
Back for another episode of Worth It.
- And we're not just noodling around here,
but we are covering noodles.
- Noodles.
We've done many types
of noodles in the past.
Pasta, spaghetti, ramen.
Today, we're focusing on
non-Italian noodles in Los Angeles.
- Today on Worth It,
we're going to be trying
three delicious noodle dishes
at three drastically
different price points
to find out which noodle is
the most worth it at its price.
Okay, so we're sticking
specifically to Asian dishes.
The first place we're going
to, where are we going?
- We're going to Lao Xi'er Noodle House
to see Joe and Ellen,
and we're having their
Wife's Special Noodle dish.
- Sweet.
Very, very sweet.
Like, the story is sweet.
- It is actually a sweet story.
(upbeat jazz music)
How did you come to start
this business together?
- It's his dream.
- I can't find my favorite noodle in LA.
- It was different than
what you were used to?
- Very different.
He wanted to keep the original
style from my hometown.
Shanxi Province, northwest of China.
- [Andrew] I'm curious
how many styles of noodle
there are from your hometown?
- [Ellen] More than a thousand different.
- More than a thousand different styles?
- Yeah.
- That's a lot.
- [Ellen] The cat's ear noodle, Mau Er Duo
also in my hometown we make a lot.
Most of the time we make
it with lamb or beef soup.
Actually, it's very similar
to, like, macaroni noodle.
Knife-cut noodle is a
flat and thick noodle.
That noodle we usually make stir-fry.
- We are focusing on the
Wife's Special Noodle dish.
Could you tell us what is
the story behind that dish?
- Introduce this.
- She's my wife.
(both laugh loudly)
(Joe speaks in foreign language)
- [Ellen] The noodle
is called Helao-style.
It's a long and thin noodle.
The machine push it to the pot directly,
so it's very very fresh.
It really only take two or
three minutes to cook it.
The first sauce, the beef
taste will be a little bit spicy
and the tomato with egg,
we just use tomato fried with egg.
A little bit sour tasting.
The ground pork just soybean
paste with ground pork.
- [Andrew] If I'm
understanding this correctly,
in your hometown it's common to eat
each of these sauces with noodles.
Sometimes people will combine two,
and you had the idea to
put all three together.
- [Ellen] Yeah.
- Why was that?
- [Ellen] The flavor will be more complex
- [Joe] Because I like this flavor.
Together have a vegetable,
and a meat, have a sour, have a salty.
One bowl is great.
(cash register dings)
- You guys also make dumplings here.
Do you have a recommendation
on which one we should try?
- Yeah, lamb dumpling, I like.
New item for me.
- [Steven] I'm gonna do it
with vinegar and chile oil.
- Dumpling cheers.
- Cheers.
(laughs) Go to the bath together.
Come on.
- [Both] Mm.
- I have to have another.
- Share some with...
Oh there it is.
- Mm.
- Want one Annie?
It's a very soft lamb flavor.
- [Steven] Very light.
- Yeah.
Yidi hasn't had one.
- Actually, the most important thing
about this dumpling, the wrapper.
- Which is the same dough as the noodles.
- This is a lot of food.
- This is a fun amount.
- Cheers.
(slurping sounds)
- Delicious noodle, yeah.
- I always love a noodle
that you can just stuff in your face.
- [Adam] You guys are monsters.
- Are we monsters?
- I'm sorry.
- I see Annie going like
this with the headphones.
It's all right, it's a
lot of slurping going on.
- I honestly have never heard
of tomato egg before today.
- This is kind of crazy
because it's like combining
all of these flavors from my childhood.
Just all of those things
are just like, whoa.
You just like (exhales).
- [Annie] Steven, that's Ratatouille.
- That's Ratatouille?
I still haven't seen that movie.
(slurping sounds)
- A thousand types of
noodles, approximately.
- So comforting.
Very, very good noodle dish.
- Before we go to our next noodle place,
we're going to a place called Bistro Na's
that does Beijing specialty desserts.
- Yes.
- And this place is recommended
by our good friend Yidi.
Do you want to finish that before we,
yeah this is the biggest
Lazy Susan I've ever seen.
- Choo-choo.
- Okay.
I said, "Yidi, where should
we get some deserts?"
And she said, "You have
to go to Bistro Na's."
Why is that?
- They have food from my hometown Beijing.
I eat here a lot to cure my homesick,
and their dessert is
something I grew up eating
so I figured you guys should try it.
- [Andrew] Wow.
- [Steven] Okay.
- Here you go, guys.
- So this is how Yidi lives.
I know exactly what I want,
but I want to ask Yidi what we should eat.
- The donkey roll.
- [Andrew] The donkey roll.
- [Yidi] Yes.
- [Andrew] Okay, do you want
to start with the donkey roll?
- That's not the best
one Yidi, you're wrong.
I'm a sesame roll kind of guy.
(soft jazzy music)
- Mm.
- Mm, good.
- Before we enjoy the
rest of these deserts,
let's enjoy a noodle fact.
- Noodle fact for your noodle.
- Oh wow, aren't all facts noodle facts?
- Yeah.
- Because they improve your noodle.
- I did that joke just now.
- The Chinese, generally speaking,
don't dry their pasta, but Italians do.
- I've never made that distinction.
- For our spaghetti episode,
we saw spaghetti extruded
but they allowed it to dry before boiling.
Whereas at Lao Xi'er, it
extruded straight into the water.
I think it's because it's not optimized
for that al dente flavor
that you get from drying.
- It explains so much of why I like
Chinese noodles more than pasta.
- Yeah?
- 'Cause they're just--
- Squishier.
- Squishier, yes.
- So for our next noodle stop,
we're going to see Bugra
at Dolan's Uyghur Cuisine
where we're going to be trying
their Big Plate Chicken.
Before we have that,
we're gonna eat the
rest of these desserts.
- Okay so cut the camera,
let us go to town.
- I like it.
- Mm.
(upbeat instrumental music)
What is Uyghur cuisine?
- The Uyghur region is located as
middle point of the Silk Road.
It's influenced by the Persian,
the Indian, Turkish and Chinese.
Many people ask, "You guys have kebab,
and you guys have some wok dish?"
"How did you invent this?"
But actually this is original Uyghur food.
Our chef, Alerken, is going
to do all dishes today.
- What are the highlight
dishes of Uyghur cuisine?
- In ancient times, the Uyghur
people do kebab in desert.
So you make a fire, and
you make that tower,
and its shape is like that fire.
Polo is very traditional
braised rice and meats,
carrots, raisins together.
Manta, it looks like
Chinese dumping but bigger.
The dough is very thin.
It's stuffed with beef
and onions and spices
- So talking about the Big Plate Chicken.
So I imagine it's big.
- Yes, it's huge.
- I thought this was a
noodle episode, Andrew.
- This is a noodle dish, right?
- Of course, yeah, it comes with noodle.
This is like very typical
Chinese and Uyghur fusion.
We fry the chicken with the
oil, and peppers and spices:
cinnamon, cumin, star
anise, sichuan pepper.
So this is spicy.
We put the potato and
we braise half an hour.
We also make the handmade noodle.
Noodle, it should be chewy.
We make the noodle with
water, salt and egg whites.
- Egg whites in the dough?
- Egg whites, yes.
Because it makes it really
chewy, and it's thick noodle.
This is the difference between
Big Plate Chicken noodle
with the other noodle dish.
It should be thick and wide.
- [Steven] I noticed with
the Big Plate Chicken,
all the noodles are covered
by the things on top.
Why are you trying to
build this mountain of meat
on top of the noodles?
- Because the Big Plate
Chicken, it has soup,
so when you eat the noodle,
mix it with the soup.
It's like, amazing taste.
(cash register dings)
- [Andrew] I have never seen
a teacup like this before.
- [Bugra] All are handmade.
- Wow.
- Handmade?
- Yeah.
Flower tea, this is very
common in my country.
This is also sort of my creation.
- Cheers.
- Don't spill the tea.
- Mm, oh yeah.
- Ooh.
- Rose.
- Is there cinnamon in here?
- Yes.
- Cinnamon.
- Cardamom.
- [Bugra] Cardamom.
- You ready for some Big
Plate Chicken Steven?
- Big Plate Chicken, here we go.
- My goodness.
Okay we got one noodle
sticking out over here.
Should we start with chicken?
- Yeah.
- Since this is Big Plate Chicken?
Wow that smells good.
(clicks tongue)
Mm, that's a little spicy, yeah.
- The taste that comes with it, linger.
- [Andrew] There we go, a noodle.
- Oh, I want one of
those kinds of noodles.
That one's been sitting below
the weight of the chicken
Got it, I got it here.
- It's delicious looking, right?
(laughs)
- Cheers
Oh, man.
- Whoa.
- The noodle itself is very dumpling like,
- Dumpling like.
- in it's softness.
- It's like you're eating
a dumpling in one noodle.
- [Andrew] It really is
like a soup at the bottom.
- I know, why don't we have a spoon?
- I think it's because
the noodle is your spoon.
(spoons clank)
- (laughs) Sound of spoons.
- As we say that.
Thank you so much.
See this peppercorn here?
It's all going in.
Oh that's so good.
- Really?
Okay I need to try it now.
- You gotta do it.
Focus in on the tongue.
- The heat builds a little bit.
The numbing peppercorn
is there a little bit.
- I love that, yeah.
- The addition of cinnamon
is really surprising and delightful.
- But it reminds me of Malaysian cuisine.
A lot of the dishes there
are literally marriages.
There's no better description of this
than a marriage of dishes.
- [Andrew] It's delicious.
- I get it.
I get why they say stop noodling around,
because it takes a long
time to eat a noodle.
Is that it?
Sometimes when you get out of a movie
and you're like, "I
don't know what to say."
- Like when you finish a good
book and you just need to
take a walk and do nothing.
- Or like a one and a half
hour drive across Los Angeles
all the way to Beverly Hills.
- Cause that's where we're going next,
but before that happens--
- Noodle fact.
Historians believe that
Chinese noodles originated
more than X years ago.
What is X?
- 1500 years ago.
- Now double that and add 1000.
4000 years ago.
- 4000 years ago?
I wonder what the first shape was.
You find that funny, Annie?
- I never thought of that before.
- Yeah, what was the first noodle shape?
- Oh, noodle shape?
- Oh noodle shape!
- I thought you were just
talking about shapes.
- Yeah, me too.
- [Adam] China has been making bread
longer than they've been making noodles,
and noodle making stemmed
from the ripping of dough
into boiling water.
- [Both] Whoa.
- Okay, going across town.
♪ Making my way across town ♪
Now we're headed to Crustacean,
a landmark Vietnamese-American spot.
We're going to be having
An's Famous Garlic Noodles,
and on top of that, Dungeness crab.
The noodles are the creation
of the founder of the
restaurant, Helene An,
and she's kept the recipe a secret.
So they are made in a secret kitchen
and we can't go in there.
- We'll be speaking with Chef Tony,
maybe he can spill the
beans on these noodles.
- That's okay, I mean,
Oprah actually filmed here
and she wasn't allowed in there,
so we're pretty much Oprah.
(everybody laughs)
(upbeat electronic music)
- I understand that your kitchen operates
somewhat in secret.
- Somewhat.
We have a kitchen within a kitchen.
That kitchen's for family members
and people that have
worked in the restaurant
for over 10 years.
- Why?
- My boss, Chef Helene
An, she first started
way back in the 70's in this little deli,
and slowly putting Asian
flairs here and there.
She knew she was on to something,
so she wanted to keep
it within the family.
We have about four items that
come from secret originally.
The garlic noodles have been
around since we've been open.
She saw that everybody
loves spaghetti and Parmesan
so that was her inspiration.
She was just named the
mother of Asian fusion.
This is the signature
dish of the restaurant.
- Asian fusion has been looked
at in a variety of ways.
Where I grew up, it was looked down on,
but you're doing Asian fusion,
and it's right here in Beverly Hills.
How are you able to flip the
narrative of Asian fusion food?
- I think it was just something cool
for people to hate on fusion,
but the way I became
very comfortable about it
is when I spoke with Helene.
She didn't really know what fusion was.
She was just like, "I'm just cooking
the way I want to cook."
Now we're grabbing from
different regions of the world,
as long as you're doing it intelligently,
the end result should be pretty tasty.
- So this is our last stop in our video,
it's the three dollar signs,
but the noodles themselves are not really
the expensive thing here, right?
- Generally if you're getting a crab
you're always getting a garlic noodle,
but they're two separate
items on the menu.
I would say 99.9% of
people that get the crab,
they always get a noodle.
- To enjoy the noodles to their best.
- This is not a question,
you have to get the crab.
(both laugh)
- Gotcha.
(cash register dings)
- Whoa.
This smells like my fire
alarm is about to go off.
(laughs)
- Look at that.
It feels like something you
shouldn't do at a restaurant
this nice but I do just
want to go (throaty laugh).
- Caviar cheers.
- Oh man, that's so awesome.
- Actually, that makes a lot of sense.
- Here we go.
Ah, there's the hit of garlic.
It takes about two seconds.
- [Tony] One crab in the shell,
and one crab picked out the shell.
- Nice.
- Wow.
And bibs?
No way.
- Yes!
This is way more simple than I thought.
- [Andrew] Right.
- Cheers.
- Oh yeah, that's really good.
I just want to eat this whole bowl.
- It's so fluffy.
Squishy, fluffy noodle.
- Fluffy noodle, yeah.
I'm gonna do a little bit of crab.
- [Steven] Isn't this the life?
Pre-picked crab.
(sensual blues music)
- It's really good, right?
- This is my fantasy as a kid
of what a dish should taste like.
- This is so close to the buttered noodles
you would eat as a kid, right?
Add on the best version
of a buttery thing,
buttery crab meat.
- Pre-picked crab, okay,
is like birds who get to eat food
that's already been chewed
up for them by their parents.
- Talking about when a
mama bird chews up food
and then throws it up into
the chickling's mouth.
- The idea of having
food prepared for you.
- It's a mothers love, right?
It's great.
- Now how do you make
it, that's the question.
(somber blues music)
Long noodles, long life.
- Long day.
- That's what they say.
One thing that was your favorite thing
that was not a noodle today?
- The noodle extruder at
Lao Xi'er Noodle House
that was like a old
fashioned manual train cart.
- At Crustacean, below the
floor, there's a fish tank
and there's a lot of beautiful
Koi fish living down there.
Okay Andrew, which noodle
was the most worth it
at it's given price?
- I'll give a honorable mention to
the Cat's Ear Noodle from Lao Xi'er.
My Worth It winner is gonna go to
Dolan's Uyghur Cuisine,
- Oh my gosh.
- So good.
- Oh my gosh, I can't believe
it, we agree for once.
I love Crustacean, and I
was gonna say Lao Xi'er
because the vast experiences
you get in one bowl.
My Worth It winner goes
to Dolan's Uyghur Cuisine.
- Adam, who is your Worth It winner?
- [Adam] Lao Xi'er.
- Annie, who is your
favorite noodle from today?
- Crustacean
- [Andrew] And Yidi, while
we're in the neighborhood.
- Donkey Roll!
(laughs)
- Well that does it for episode two
in our end of year miniseries.
Come back next week for
a very crispy conclusion.
- It also has soft ends.
- [Adam] Fried Chicken Sandwich.
- Aw, come on Adam.
(gentle piano music)
- All right Steven, this will be
our final Worth It episode for 2019.
- Today on Worth It,
we're going to be trying
three fried chicken sandwiches
at three drastically
different price points
to find out which one is the
most Worth It at its price.
- I think we're
experiencing, at the moment,
a little bit of a fried
chicken sandwich craze.
We thought we'd investigate the issue
and do fried chicken sandwiches ourselves.
- I like what you said, "investigate."
- Oh look at that, fresh asphalts.
- The way you say words (laughs)
- It's look golden and delicious
the way fresh fried chicken does.
Doesn't that look delicious?
That looks tasty,
what?
So the first place we're heading to is
The Window At American Beauty.
Chef Elisha is going to be showing us
their fried chicken sandwich.
American Beauty is a steakhouse.
And during the day,
they have a to-go window
that does things like burgers, fries,
fried chicken sandwiches, obviously.
- I like that a lot,
it feels very New York.
I don't know where I'm going with that.
I just like it, I just like New York.
(atmospheric music)
- What is The Window?
- So The Window is our daytime operation
where we serve delicious food
at a very affordable price.
- [Steven] As I understand it,
this chicken sandwich is under six bucks?
- [Chef Elisha] Yeah, it's
five dollars and 50 cents.
- Wow.
- That is crazy.
- I don't know if I'd
say we're competition
with fast-food, but we're
trying to hit around
the price point of the
regular fast-food chains.
We're making everything in house
and the idea is to deliver
hospitality to our guests,
whether they order the fried
chicken sandwich at the window
or they're ordering our steaks at night.
So we butterfly the
chicken, so it spreads out,
we pound it so it's the
same thickness around.
- [Andrew] I saw that you
were also scoring the meat
before you were pounding it.
- [Chef Elisha] By scoring
it, we're both helping
the buttermilk and the
seasoning penetrate,
but also we're getting a
little bit more surface space,
so there's a little
bit more crunchy parts.
And then we just fry it.
We have the awesome Martin's Potato Rolls.
The jalapeño aioli,
which gives a little bit
more fat and some heat.
And then we have this very simple slaw
that gives a little freshness.
Just cabbage, some carrots, red onion,
and a very simple red wine vinaigrette.
- [Steven] Is that what you would say
makes a perfect fried chicken sandwich?
Is it the balance of all
of those things together?
- [Chef Elisha] For
me, I think it's really
the combination of it all.
It's an evolution while you're eating it.
And as it goes, it's kinda
all compliments itself.
And I think that really makes for a better
and more enjoyable eating experience.
(cash register dings)
- [Announcer] Order for Worth It.
- That's our order!
- Thank you guys!
- Thank you.
- Oh, that smells amazing.
- Oh!
- Sorry, I just want that.
- That was a hard hit.
There's something about food in a box
like this that I just love every time.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's like the American Bento Box.
- Nice.
- Do you eat ketchup with your fries?
- I do.
- Okay, hold on, I got you.
- All right.
I took a fry, I mean what?
- You what?
You're lucky I don't dump
this ketchup on your head.
- Do it, I dare you.
Fries.
(video game music)
- Mm, incredible fry.
It's crunchy like cereal is crunchy.
- [Steven] Okay, lets go sando' time.
- Oh, look at that.
- Whoa!
It feels fluffier than I thought.
- That's that potato bun.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
(upbeat music)
- Mm!
- Mm.
Yeah, that was a really good first bite.
- [Andrew] Wow.
- Mm!
That was a really good second bite.
- I have a feeling every
bite is going to be good.
- What I'm realizing about this bun,
it's so soft and fluffy
that it's doing its job
in like making the fried chicken
the real star of the show.
- So this is the, "why are we having
fried chicken sandwich"
as a question, you know?
'Cause we've done fried chicken before,
but the bun just dials
the whole thing back
into like soft doughnut territory.
- Mm-hmm.
- Which I kind of like.
You know what this does
kind of remind me of?
- Tell me.
- I think you're going
to be mad that you didn't think of this.
- No, I think this is going to be
less exciting than I thought.
- The peking duck bun
that we had in New York.
That soft, squishy bun
with a delicious meat
and condiment and crispy vegetable.
Plus the cucumber and the sauce
that adds a little sweetness.
- Yeah, yeah.
You're right, okay, yeah.
(video game music)
- American Beauty, what a
beautiful time in America.
- That's too easy for
you, I'm disappointed.
- Okay, so before our next proper
fried chicken sandwich,
we're actually gonna
have a bonus piece of fried chicken.
(Steven sighs)
Friend of the show, David Chang,
has a number of fried chicken
sandwich shops called Fuku.
They have an off menu,
mega spicy, fried chicken
designed to taste better
as a cold product.
It's like a food pun but in the language
of flavor and temperature.
- It sounds more like an oxymoron.
- It's like a fun--
- You'd have to be an
oxy-moron to eat this.
Aah!
- Okay you know what's terrifying?
Black gloves that come with your food.
Here it is, oh, whew!
Put your gloves on. (laughs)
This guy's walking his
dog and is just looking
at three guys putting on black gloves.
(dramatic music)
Oh my god!
It looks upsetting.
- Why!
Oh!
- It looks like mummified meat.
- Why is it so dark? (laughs)
- Adam, I wish you had that
bottle of ranch on standby.
- Oh! (laughs)
- I thought we were just dipping!
(laughs) Adam!
This is so bizarre.
- Oh, it's cold! (laughs)
- Cheers!
(dramatic music)
Oh, it's not too bad.
Oh!
- Oh, it's like cinnamon-sugary too.
- Oh!
- It's bad.
- There's pickles that you
can have along side (sighs).
(sighs) No, I don't like this.
- Give me the fact!
- Okay.
Hot-cold fried chicken fact time.
Mm, that's good, an ice, slush drink.
- It's making it worse.
- Can you say hot-cold fact chicken time?
- Hot-Cold Fact Chicken time!
(Adam sneezes)
(laughs) Oh, wow!
- The chemical in spicy foods that
makes something spicy is capsaicin.
Capsaicin is known to increase
energy, reduce appetite,
increase salivation,
and release endorphins.
(laughing)
- Ability to taste reduces
in higher temperatures,
above 86 degrees Fahrenheit,
as well as lower temperatures
below 68 degrees Fahrenheit.
Oh!
- I think this chicken might
be right in the center.
You're still going?
- Oh my goodness!
- So we're on our way
downtown to Pikunico.
We're going to see chef Kuniko
and have her fried chicken sandwich.
- Okay, is it spicy?
- No, it's okay.
- Okay, good.
- Yeah.
(atmospheric music)
- Pikunico means picnic plus Kuniko.
So everything is in a to-go
box and you can eat outside
of the restaurant, like a picnic.
- Why did you choose fried chicken
as the cornerstone of the menu?
- I grew up with it.
My grandma never liked cooking,
so we'd always go buy it. (laughs)
When I came here, I ate this
southern style fried chicken,
with thick, thick crust and I
loved it, so I did a hybrid.
Light, as Japanese, but
also with a crunchiness.
Normally it's a wheat flour,
but we do brown rice and potato starch.
That's maybe the most special
part of our fried chicken.
Our fryer don't carry any gluten.
A lot of my friends' kids,
they have serious allergy,
and they never eaten fried chicken.
So I said, okay you can come here.
- [Andrew] Why did you want
to offer a sandwich option
for your fried chicken?
- I'm trying to belong here. (laughs)
- [Andrew] Do you ever
find those in Japan?
- [Kuniko] I don't believe
it's a popular thing.
Japanese just pack rice balls,
and fried chicken, and pickles.
And that's our picnic.
But a lot of people said, "Kuni, come on,
like you're living in the United States,
everyone loves sandwich,
come up with a great one."
I wanted to make the sandwich
as special as I could.
We created a golden bun
which carries turmeric.
The turmeric is antiinflammatory.
So you can lessen your feeling
of I'm eating fried
chicken today. (laughs)
To me, sandwich is about combination.
The soft bun, crunchy chicken,
acid from lemon vinaigrette.
I want it to have everything in one bite.
- I mean you say one bite,
but I've seen the sandwich,
and it's quite tall.
- Yes.
- How do I eat that with one bite?
- Smoosh. (laughs)
(cash register dings)
- We've come for the sandwiches,
but we also got a salad
that we're going to try first.
- [Kuniko] I like my
seaweed and cucumber salad.
Our seaweed is from Japan
and it's salt cured.
The texture is not like dehydrated,
like wakame, like paper thin.
It's very meaty and satisfying.
I eat my salad everyday.
- Cheers.
(atmospheric music)
- Mm!
- Wow.
- I'm not sure I've ever had
this type of seaweed before.
It is denser and meatier.
- Pause button, back to the sandwich.
She gave us good advice to smoosh.
- Look at how juicy the chicken is.
Do you see the juices coming out?
It's the hidden benefit of the squish.
- Cheers.
- That's awesome.
- Wow.
- That's a face wiper, for sure.
It's a very good sandwich.
- Dude, the star of this
fried chicken sandwich.
- Say it on three, one
- Two, three.
- The pickles.
- The bread.
Oh, defend your case because
I think you're wrong.
- It's the sourness that makes
you want all the other stuff.
- True, but come on, look at this bread.
It's squishy, has a nice
bite, it's not falling apart.
- It's a beautiful sandwich.
The texture of this stuff,
almost like moss-like.
You ever look at moss and
think, I bet that's tasty?
- I never think that, no.
- Really?
I think it'd be a cool texture to eat.
It's like a hanging garden.
- It's like that plant up there.
I think this makes like
potentially the perfect sandwich.
You've got this fried
chicken that's delicious.
But then, the things
surround it so you're not
feeling like greasy.
- [Andrew] It's not greasy at all.
- There's fried chicken
is on this side, right.
So she's like, okay, what
do I put on this side
to balance it out.
- Sprouts, miso jam,
pickles, a little too far.
- Oh, okay.
- Jalapeños on this side, boom.
I feel like we've said some good stuff.
- Ooh.
- Dirty move Adam.
That's a dirty, dirty move.
Are you using the one that you
didn't already steal a
piece of chicken out of?
I see, I know how you work.
Pikunico, what do you think?
- The bread, it's so good.
- Ooh, I feel like a picnic.
Does that make any sense?
- No.
Before we go to our next spot,
Fried Chicken Sandwich Fact time!
- Fried Chicken Sandwich fact.
- Though it's not currently on the menu,
for a time, KFC offered
the Double Down sandwich,
I remember that one.
Which consisted of two
fried chicken filets
doubling as the bun
and the filling was
bacon, cheese, and sauce.
I actually have a very
fond memory of this.
- You actually ate this thing?
- I tried it.
It was as amazing as it sounds.
- Really?
I remember that thing, that was madness.
It's like, just eat food
guys, what are you doing?
Is it even a sandwich at that point
or are you just picking up food?
Like if I just pick up a
steak and eat it with my hand,
is that a sandwich?
- [Adam] If you have two of them.
- We started this video at a steakhouse,
now we're going to a seafood restaurant.
- Oh, okay
- We're on our way to Son
of a Gun, where Chef Greg
is going to show us their
fried chicken sandwich,
and probably a couple
other seafood treats.
(electronic music)
Is this modeled after a certain style
or like genre of seafood?
- Definitely, Jon and Vinny
the owners are from Florida,
the vibe of it is the Florida fish shack.
- [Steven] I wanna know why you
put a fried chicken sandwich
on a menu of a seafood restaurant.
- [Greg] Well our menu is really diverse,
which is like the way we like to eat.
Living in Los Angeles, you
have so much diversity,
there's amazing food in Korea
Town, amazing Chinese food in
San Gabriel, you name it we got it here.
So this is what influences our menu,
we're not an Italian restaurant,
we're not a French restaurant,
we just take something
that we're into at the time
and try to develop a dish.
- [Andrew] The tuna dish for example--
- [Greg] Exactly yeah, that
tuna dish is influenced by
Peruvian cuisine, first
we take market avocado,
red onion, cilantro,
and some tortilla chips.
Mix all that together,
and then the tuna has been
pounded out into carpaccio,
so it makes the texture
of the fish really nice.
So that gets wrapped
around the avocado mix,
and then the bottom of the
bowl is a leche de tigre,
so, you eat it with a spoon
and get a little bit of the tuna,
the avocado, the tortilla
chips all together.
- Ohh.
Thank you.
- Wow.
- [Steven] This is delightful.
- This reminds me of our time
at Pacific Seas, remember that?
I don't exist in this bar as you know me.
- We've shared like one donut.
(clapping)
Wait, whoa.
- Thank you.
- Okay
These are the coolest
straws I've ever seen.
- This is a drink you
don't have to cheers.
'Cause how would you?
- Like this.
(upbeat music)
- I'm concerned because I
taste no alcohol in there.
But I definitely feel alcohol in here.
- [Steven] Alright, oyster time.
- [Andrew] Mmm, yeah, mignonette me.
- [Steven] And then you want a
horse radish or are you good?
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Cheers
Ohhh
- Mmm, Hell yeah
- Okay turn it up
- Oh my god.
I think oysters are the
most Disney princess food.
It's like a spoon made of an ocean fish,
and so it makes me feel
like I'm in Little Mermaid.
You get what I mean?
- No, I'm not, I'm not picking
up what you're laying down.
- People are shaking their heads
but those people haven't
been having scorpion bowl.
- [Steven] Whoa.
- [Andrew] This is the wildest
looking thing I've ever seen.
It looks like a whole brain on a plate.
- Whoa.
- Wow.
(upbeat music)
- Goddammit that's good.
Oh my God, that's good.
- [Steven] Look at how
much avocado is in this.
- And this juice at the bottom
is like spicy orange juice.
- This tastes more like
a cocktail than this.
- Yeah.
- Hold up.
- [Andrew] No Steven, you're a mad man.
(slurping sounds)
(Steven coughs)
(Andrew laughs)
- [Greg] A lot of people have asked if
we could make a cocktail
out of the leche de tigre
- I was saying, it tastes
more like a cocktail
than the scorpion bowl does.
- I said that, not you.
- [Greg] We take a
free-range chicken breast,
brined overnight in some lemon and herbs,
bread it with a three-step
breading process,
seasoned flour into buttermilk,
and then we make crumbs
out of the flour and the
buttermilk, so it gives it
a little bit of a crispy
texture when we fry the chicken.
Then let it rest, let the
juices reabsorb in, and then we
use red rooster aioli which
is red rooster hot sauce from
Louisiana and it's not Sriracha,
it's more like Tabasco.
And then we make a slaw
with market vegetables,
we make some bread and
butter pickles in house here,
so we'll make the dressing
for the cabbage slaw
from the vinegar that
comes from the pickles.
(cash register dings)
- Okay
- Here's the fried
chicken sandwich guys.
- Thank you
- Okay, that's actually
not at all what I expected to see.
There's pickles embedded into the slaw.
- It's my kind of slaw.
Have you ever seen a more
beautiful chicken sandwich?
Commercial perfect.
Okay, I'm gonna split it for us.
You're gonna love the feel of
this bun, I can already tell.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, you're a big bun guy.
- Oh, these dishes are
actually very similar.
There's like the
fattiness and the acidity.
- Yeah
- Fattiness, acidity
- Oyster
- Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
- You're gonna set me up like
that, I'm gonna dunk hard.
How's that for a sports analogy?
Cheers Steven
- Cheers.
(groovy music)
Oh no.
You know you had a good time
when the sandwich is in shambles.
- What do you think about the
texture of the fried crust?
- It sounds like you wanna
talk about the texture
of the fried crust, Andrew.
- Yeah, you know how there's
different levels of crunch.
A crunchier crunch would be
like leaves, high pitch crackle,
then there's also lower pitch crackle,
like stepping into snow.
I think this is more like snow crackle
and the other chicken we've
had is more like leaf crackle.
Was that too long winded?
- I wanna spend a day in your head.
Just like, what are you thinking?
(groovy music)
- All right Steven.
- We did it again.
- Not only did we have three
fried chicken sandwiches,
but this also concludes a
three episode set for us.
The first one had buns,
the last one had buns.
In effect it was a sandwich of its own.
What was your favorite
thing in this episode
that was not a fried chicken sandwich?
- The giant ropes that held
the hanging light bulbs at Pikunico.
- Hmm yes.
We don't often get to talk
about restaurant decor.
I kinda have a similar favorite thing
that wasn't a fried chicken sandwich.
- Aha.
- The bathroom faucets at American Beauty.
It looked like a swan throwing
up the water into your hands.
- All right, which fried chicken sandwich
was the most worth it at its given price?
- My Worth It winner goes to
The Window at American Beauty.
That fried chicken sandwich
is everything I wanted
on a Martin's Potato Roll,
which is near and dear to my heart.
- You're not often wrong on the
show, but you're wrong today
- Oh (bleep)
- My Worth It winner goes to Pikunico.
That fried chicken sandwich
was so smoosh-able.
- Yeah.
The smooshing today was pretty excellent.
Adam, who's your Worth It winner?
- [Adam] Pikunico
- Adam picks Pikunico.
A good pick unico.
- Unico.
- And that's gonna be it for 2019.
Thanks to everybody who works on this show
to make it happen, most
of them are not here.
- And thank you all for watching.
- Yeah
- We appreciate it.
We'll be back.
If you wanna suggest a food,
we do check our Instagram page
instagram.com/buzzfeedworthit
- And the comments of this video
- Comments of this video
- We're probably reading them right now
as you're watching this.
I am also watching.
Oh yeah, what did we
learn about fried chicken?
- Its delicious.
- Well fried chicken
sandwiches may continue
to be eaten the world round,
at least we'll know that they taste good.
Solved. (laughs)
(triumphant music)